night before the lease was supposed to  get signed partner couldn't come up with  half the money to do the gym the night  before I ended up assuming the entire  gym how much did that cost so it was  supposed to be both we're gonna put 25  Grand in and I had 60. it went from me  having some padding to notepadding so it  was 50 Grand and I had 60. and so I had  10 000 left which is enough for two  months rent at that gym so I started  sleeping at the gym because I couldn't  afford two rents I remember selling the  entire first month and making exactly 4  973 which is the exact amount of the  rent and so then I just watched it go  back down to zero and I was like this  sucks the next month we made 10 grand  the next month made 15 then 20 then 20  it was like five grand a month all the  way up to like 35 000 a month I started  hiring people and bringing people in and  then by month like nine it was all  outsourced so I had the like a manager  and some trainers and whatnot